what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to start up Black Mirror
season six kicking it off with Joan is awful
episode one John how's it going good I'm ready
to feel terrible and want to take a shower after
ladies and gentlemen you know what I'm gonna say
please go ahead leave a like that would mean
the world also subscribe click the notification
Bell because we're gonna be covering all the
Black Mirror season six so that way you can
get notified when our next reaction is up here on
this Chanel also want to give a mention too thank
you to everyone who bought our latest shirt at
shopzeroedition.com we have a Batman inspired one
and one that I have been wanting to create for
such a long time so we have it right here look
at it and you know what there's even a better
quality image right here on screen for you all
got Michael Keaton Robert Pattinson bat flecking
there because they're the ones in the DC Universe
at the moment I love it you'll be seeing us rocket
during the flash spoiler talk live stream and also
full interaction watch along where you sync up
with your own copy of Black Mirror available for
her super sexy rejects over at her patreon page
but with this being the very first episode that
one is made public for everyone so there's a
link in the description box and pin comment if
you you prefer to sync up with us and watch the
entire experience because obviously this reaction
highlights so can't feature a good amount of
it anywho guys let's swing into action people
it looks like the Netflix look
oh it's her from shit's creek
Thomas that's not your neck better tap in
tap tap tap uh tech company Sandy
is outside waiting for that 10 15.
I know give me five I need to like
let's hang up throw on some more tunes
oh she's having an affair do it
I'm sorry it's how the board feel I just
put a deposit down on a new apartment
please don't do this doing her job
man I really I am so sorry about this
I
have this dude arises of Ezra Miller
you the letter you're looking for
use chat gbt to have your affair
no oh no I know it used to be my
dream to run my own coffee shop
that would not have gone out with our name
on it I'm engaged to Chris yes so good
maybe he's just a little bit like vanilla when
I was with my ex Mack yeah um I mean it was just
constant sex and craziness don't confuse toxicity
with passion great and then I met Krish and he was
sweet and safe and so I just kind of went
with the flow that's love I feel like I'm
not the main character in my own life story
you're NPC and would you like that to change
that actually felt like a
real therapy session thank you
yep embrace your Wild Side this
is good your fiance would love
this I love your hair like that the streaks yeah
he I was uh well Phyllis at the salon deserves
a raise because you look hot as [__]
in my life you pop back up like a [__] like an
unflushed turd that's sexy I want to be with you
it's too late man
you can't leave a crash oh my God you've been at
this dinner for what feels like five minutes cut
the tension with a knife who needs to eat I'm in
my usual sweet and I'll be here for three days
comedian guy from Deadpool 2 Rob Delaney
I want to say I hope you're hungry
amazing is that salt
and pepper strain barrier
oh my God it's Netflix yes oh
so it's saying Joan is awful
was intentionally supposed to look
like nothing oh my it's just Netflix
yeah oh my God this is so meta
this is Salma Hayek she looks like her oh
my God uh what oh my God is this like some
algorithm thing that channels who you
really are oh my God it's a lot like
your hair and she's even called Joan okay
what even is the show this feels like a
Scream movie I would love an algorithm
to mirror me watching a show about a
reactor right now a reaction within a
reaction by the guy who plays crucial
no [__] the guy from yesterday
and mesh Patel that's not my hair
it's a different ethnicity you know it's woke
Joan is awful the show is woke the race Bender
oh my God is the message from Matt gonna be there
boy it's called Joan is awful
it's got Salma Hayek in it
she looks like John oh my
Joan is awful what the [__]
dreaming they're like all
remixes of Black Mirror episodes
I've never responded that way to
a notification from Netflix before
Black Mirror
but this is like mirroring today
that crank these shows out fast how
did I this is a prank how did you do this
well I didn't I don't find a [__] bunny
I didn't do anything not so vanilla
now is it spice up the relationship
new episodes every day for the rest of
your life also Sandy is waiting for that
10 15. is he still there he's still there
oh my God is that really what I sound like
it must be some like AI generator that uses
them chronologically how would they really
achieve this I just put pause it down on
an apartment you see what she's like oh
my God she is cold are you not freaked out yeah
come on this is your day too I did not say that
like that that is not what happened I believe
you Jesus Christ y'all gotta turn this off man
card okay hey look I was just trying to
make you feel she intentionally tosses it
oh my God my mom seen it
what everybody can see this
my dad's seen it why is everyone deciding
to watch Joan as awful Jesus Christ oh no
oh no oh Jesus has Mac been texting you what
no I hope you deleted those messages I want
to keep watching no no hey Chris I want it
off no how's life at home oh no he's coming
very vanilla even he's cooking is Bland
no Mac there was so much crazy wild
oh my God I'm allergic to uncomfortableness I
haven't gotten over Mike I crash I think maybe
I don't want some ways this
is her more honest self
yeah without the posturing hey Ben Barnes
that's what I think hey no some of the details
the whole thing it's just it's blown
out of proportion I'm packing my eggs
ah no no
psycho just repeats itself oh my God
oh no that's good that's good
that's not my hair she looks good
show me your phone what uh it's in
the house it's convenient kill me
goodbye you know all you have to do was go
I'll go get it and then on your way back please
nah man you cheated you had it coming
they're right about Ninja you're awful
the title Joan you just kind
of embrace who you really are
it's going to be on television
everything you do yes
thank you shame on you everybody's
time it's all anyone can talk about
how did it come across technically you're broke
your NDA what what how the board wants you out now
become the monster everyone
thinks you are get those ratings
even her therapist is gonna be like I don't want
to work with you anymore you're terrible this is
sayonara Queen
I have to say that actually legally
the streamberry corporation can do this
what do you agree to when you use Netflix
yeah what's in the TOs terms and conditions
I have never seen this before everyone's going
to be checking their Netflix account yeah
okay well Salma Hayek yeah pretty cool
no well it's not really Salma Hayek
yes it is show deploys a digital like this of
Miss Hyatt it's the only way they could do it
she licensed Her Image to them yeah the entire
show is CGI of course there's no way they could
turn around that fast how do they even know what
I'm doing it's the same it's the same day well you
know when you got your phone face down on the
table and yeah cameras everywhere microphones
it makes me look worse than I really am
so defamation yeah page 53 paragraph 12.
creating characters and
dialogue for dramatic purposes
they got you every which way and then
some my advice is to try and ignore it
doesn't live Off the Grid or crazy level of
exploitation you could just make this work
in your favor become like an influencer
yeah I'm famous the real life Joan you
could you could totally Market yourself
yeah tell all book everything turn left
in a reality show there's a way to make it
work I'm just saying there's a way to record
you're the main character now of your life
story congratulations you got what you wanted
oh oh boy oh I can't wait
for this to be dramatized
no it's gonna be on TV
this is gonna be on the show
I'm gonna be the guy who can't get it up for Salma
Hayek wanting to not be able to get it up for you
I didn't agree to be a public figure neither
did I except you did but if you have stream
Berry you did too they if they're using your
thing everyone who has stream Berry agreed to it
would there be some level of outrage yeah he's
doing sucks that she's the first person they
could make her orangutan if they wanted although
I am guessing the real Miss Blackjack might
I don't know what she's what she's
into you don't know okay Blanchard idea
gonna do start doing wacky stuff
what
destroy your insides
super embarrassing I guess anyone knows a
reason why these two may not Merry Christmas
do it
Wowie
holy [__] uh
Salma Hayek wouldn't want to have this
image why don't you just make a public
statement and talk about what the show
is doing because it's already been on
the show I just feel like there's a lot of
different ways I should have gone about this
Martin
he's turning into Harley Quinn
never mind while this nightmares I thought
I'd see myself defecating in a church yep
do they have your face or my face your
face so then Jose is doing the [__]
what ride do they have to kill my abuela
with these deep fake heretic abomination
specifically covers any Acts or behaviors Joan
May exhibit up to including and Beyond defecation
laughs I mean doesn't my Apple have any rights
okay okay I'm going to start reading the fine
print shove it up your ass and I hope that you
get paper cards in your cameras and die yes
it's almost a Tim Burton
quality about this episode yeah
oh my God it's like a cinematic
crossover's about to happen
it's like when the xaviors met each other this
is a Multiverse get Kate Blanchett over here
please don't kill me so much you're lucky I'm a
humanitarian if you don't have any self-respect
that's your thing but to disrespect the
church frankly to disrespect my image
I lose my job they put my entire existence out
there for everyone to watch and you signed up
to be the face of it you're a [__]
enabler I should be yelling at you I'm
that I shot in a church they
told me to go [__] myself
look I didn't think it was going to be like
my movie Frida but I couldn't imagine that it
was gonna be this I feel like this is Netflix
just like flexing yeah look what we can get
away with it we could do anything pay for
your password George Clooney is gonna be
in this show no they're sticking
his head on the Thomas the Tank
Engine reboot yes I mean how do you
think Kate Blanchett feels about this
they have taken 100 Years of
Cinema and diminished it to an app
Netflix has never been more narcissistic
the computer thing oh yeah let's
are you a hacker no no no no no I mean I mean
like physically so yeah office space style her
office is all the way at the top we can't crawl
on the side of the building like Spider-Man
you can just walk in the front door
you can because you're so [__] Hayek
but isn't all this going to be on the
television yeah I am some [__] Hayek yes
although Black Mirror is just evolved into
being way more comedic is there a restaurant
I can use of course I'm afraid that's too
public thanks to your show all they can
think about is coming out of my bottom of
course and don't worry I'm just gonna be
she leave the purse there intentionally
it's gonna be able to hack into the systems
downstairs asking to see you didn't tell
us yourself this morning maybe that's why
it's got security to Chuck her out
psycho repeats Battle Rapper this whole
floor is dedicated to content generation
r d not prophetic an infinite content creator
capable of willing entire multiverses into
existence fully edited programs that
would normally take months to make such as
Joan is awful writers strike schmider's strike
what's so special about her absolutely nothing
we were looking for a totally average nobody
personally just keep getting her to launch
unique tailored content to each individual
in our database all 800 million of them wow
everyone gets a show about them there's
one for you I couldn't resist yeah
this is actually real and will be available to
stream from Friday why are they all called is
awful yeah does anybody have other qualities we
did try more affirmative content in the test cell
but we found people like the drama what we found
instead was when we focused on their more weak
or selfish or Craven moments it confirmed their
innermost fears wants to watch a reality show with
no drama I wonder if this is based on real Market
testing at Netflix it's an interesting experiment
because it's a combination of a reality show meets
dramatized television it's kind of interesting
if everyone becomes aware that it's
Michael Sarah hey what's that that's
the variant of Jonah's awful that the Joan
below you sees when she watches the show
what whoa well you're not the
original Joan that's Source Joan
Source Joan the real Joan look there
Source Stone we inside the show
I'm not the real Joe
played by a digital likeness of Annie Murphy who's
Annie Murphy there look familiar shit's creek
oh my God this is an adaptation of Joan's
life you're in a show right now I'm in a
show right now what the hell who could afford
a place like that it's a TV show House yes I
am myself yeah yeah but it tracks that you
believe that because you're coded to play
yourself on this level if I'm not here then
where am I I don't know where the real this
is not called Salma Hayek gets everything
explained to her but doesn't understand it
I'm not Eddie Murphy Source Jones break the
machine God you are so boring I'm gonna kill
here but you're not really in the yeah you're
gonna kill yourself you billions of similar
they're not real though would I die instantly
what the [__] is down Ronnie Murphy no yeah
Source Joan already stood here in
reality so okay it doesn't matter
what I want because in the events that this
is based on have already happened exactly wow
Jones doing it laughs computer
Jesus
yes wait
get black [__] in there whoa
just taking it slow yeah and trying to make
some time for myself this commentary of what
real people look like is fascinating
like the main character in my own life
yeah I think I do inspiring you
know there's good days and bad days
to be expected coffee another shooting this life
an independent drama you're really there yeah
it's not good oh her dream
hi John hi Abby how you doing
she was able to open up her own coffee shop
yeah all right well that was fun that was a
lot of fun what'd you think John take it away
that was a lot of fun yeah certainly I mean
God I almost needed a minute to put my head back
together I appreciate it you know obviously just
like the fun wild Meadow wackiness of it and
certainly I guess this commentary that like you
really should read the the terms and conditions
uh because I don't know I mean yeah not that
anything like this has happened but certainly it
is one of those things that comes up frequently
in our lives I mean this this is yeah I mean the
amount of times I hear people commenting on oh
I just mentioned a thing and now it's all over
my algorithms and stuff like that like yeah as
as silly and far-fetched of a concept as this
is in some ways I'm like well actually would
you think about it it's not that crazy with
the Advent of AI and all these other things
um and yeah I I liked the kind of mad capness
they managed to ring out of it like it doesn't
necessarily feel like the most heavy thinker of
an episode necessarily but for the kickoff to the
new season I thought it was kind of a nice place
to start and a nice way to get that foreboding
Black Mirror sense without making me feel like
my soul has just been you know run through some
kind of Filth machine or something like that uh
but what did you think yeah I liked it overall I
I do kind of miss those days of black I mean not
even the last season really had that like I like
the Striking vipers episode of Anthony Mackey
uh but even that didn't have the full sense of
the old days of Black Mirror you know when it
you're left like just miserable it has escalated
a little bit more uh like it's self-awareness
has reached this whole new level of like comedic
effect yeah it's kind of been that way for a
while yeah and so yeah like and I enjoyed it
though I think I think the commentary is fun
and I like the play on it is really does feel
like a Netflix Flex like the the metaness
of this is very fascinating to me because
it's it's a commentary on the service itself that
we are all watching this from and it's warning us
of the dangers of the service but Netflix is so
confident and it's IP and the fact that we will
still consume it and nothing's going to change
that it's saying that we can even present you with
this alternate reality possible the future that
you might actually one day sort of have something
similar to and we're just gonna do it while
collecting money from you right yeah exploiting
you yeah it's such a it's such a multi-layer of
exploitation in a way that's like this should be a
cautionary Tale But the cautionary tale is coming
from the people who stand to benefit from it in
the most sadistic way so it's a really like weird
viewership experience you know like it feels like
I almost feel like I'm I'm a masochistic viewer
in a way because I'm indulging and I'm enjoying
it and liking what they're saying but also going
is there anything I should be listed are they
like warning me the their plan of war attack that
they're about to put on the masses it was all here
it does have that bit of a bit of an effect though
you know yeah so I like the fun uh unnerving side
of it because it's easy to look at something like
this and go well that's never gonna happen uh I
don't know I wouldn't say never though maybe not
on this like Grand level of a scale uh but maybe
you know because there is that thing where uh
you know D fakes and AI technology and they're
constantly trying to use like AI generation you
know like we're at a point in our lives were
you CGI a person in frame it still looks cgi'd
uh you know so we haven't gone that far yet uh
but uh in terms of the story itself like if we
were to like there's there's two sides to talk
about this you have the commentary about we could
talk about what the episode is talking about and
then we could talk about the actual execution of
the episode the actual execution of the episode
was cool to me where when they do introduce it
it's it's kind of a slow setup but that's to get
you acquainted with her normal ordinary lifestyle
and I did have a thought when I was watching um
how how things were progressing and the way uh
Jones Life Annie Murphy's life not any Murphy
right yeah yeah she's Joan level one yeah okay
Joan level one sorry confused on this the way
Joan level one's life was progressing that it
still feels like it's shot like a cinematic
television show though yeah and then they're
doing the show on stream Berry that is just
a little more dramatized and and performative
yeah you know it's more acting-y and all that
stuff but it still looks so similar yeah right
so the when the twist came in of that oh this is
level one and we are still watching a simulation
uh I appreciated that because I was like okay well
then then that criticism not even a criticism
but just a minor nitpick that I thought would
help differentiate it a little bit more make it
seem a little more believable like okay this makes
sense more it made more sense to me now yeah yeah
because the visual aesthetic is very different
when you hop into the real world like okay so that
was all purposeful yeah so that was a nice choice
um what you think of the comedy though there were
times that comedy was like real because it became
so comedic yeah yeah it's so like kind of sharply
satirical rather than that like that I I yeah like
Black Mirror up until like this point has had
a sort of pitch black sense of humor and I I do
think it's maybe telling the Charlie Brooker back
in the day was like I gotta stop this for a while
because like it's getting too close to real life
and I wonder if in coming back and and you know
reigniting the show again maybe there was sort of
an idea that we'll make this a little bit lighter
and a little more broad or something like that and
it didn't it didn't bother me like I guess it does
make the show overall feel a bit lighter so I I
guess you know you want that oomph that impact you
know that that thing that makes your soul feel a
little dirty after a black mirror but at the same
time I don't begrudge at that it didn't break
the illusion it didn't break the story for me
um and there was a lot that I did find quite
outrageous and and funny along the way and
certainly as the layers of meta start to crash
together and as uh uh you know level one Jones
starts to take control and and you know really go
for it I I like the that reveal of of like oh okay
if I'm doing any of this this has already happened
and uh and yeah like you know life is absurd
enough already and I wonder too if any of this was
based on like actual notes they'd received about
stuff over time or or have been able to like have
access to um but yeah it is like markedly more
even more comedic to me just like less Grim
I guess is what I would go with in in terms
of an assessment um and two I mean I thought
that like like any time you make a game out
of celebrities too there's like a lightness
that comes with that and certainly this has
like a huge cast once you get right down
to like every different level and every
different version so like there was a lot of
fun I had with those games but it does feel
markedly like it's not trying to like warp
your soul so much with what it's doing which
uh which you know I'm curious to see if that
flavor comes back up throughout the rest of
the season maybe this is just a more palatable
one to get us started or something like that
I don't really care if it's doing that it was
really the the comedy to me started losing some
of its sense of believability like when it
became when Salma Hayek it was it was when
Salma Hayek entered the picture of Salma Hayek
it started feeling like okay this is not feeling
it's it's it's it's it's approached a new level
of I'm very much aware now that I'm watching a
television show and this this constant joke it's
starting to turn like this is the end all of a
sudden and this joke of like constantly pulling
it pulling the joke of constantly saying yourself
like Salma Hayek Salma Hayek like keep pointing
out it's Salma Hayek it's saying her name and
also with her acting it was just so if you can't
it just became a very different kind of comedic
sensibility sure at that point where I was now
like now I'm watching a comedy versus I'm watching
something that has humor in it okay yeah I see
what you mean and maybe that maybe that's the
point I've gotten it there um I guess it didn't
fully jive with me when it got to that point
uh it's it it started losing some of its Intrigue
I would say yeah I'm actually I'd be very curious
to hear what people think in general of that
because part of my brain says okay well it has to
be this sort of AI Amalgamated representation of
what we all think of and perceive Salma Hayek as
um so in in some sense I don't begrudge at
that because it makes sense when the reveal
comes around but in the real time of the moment
of trying to believe that oh it's the real Salma
Hayek coming to the real Jones house before
we know she's not the real Joan uh yeah I can
absolutely see how that part doesn't read quite
as real and reads like oh we're having fun with
the fact that it's really Salma Hayek rather than
just trying to portray it naturalistically in that
in that passage of the story yeah it was so it
was always still enjoyable to me and I did like
the arc that Joan level one had because so much
of her anxiety comes from a place of not feeling
like she has control over her life in situations
and then the key to finding her resolve is to
relinquish control and surrender to it which
allows her to get her Freedom by the end yeah
so I I did uh I did think the The Arc of that
was cool the Michael Sarah Cameo was fun yeah
um but I also I did like the I did like the
concept though of an out a streaming service
that can duplicate your life in real time like AI
generation is very is very fast uh you know it's
faster than it's ever been uh with a lot of a lot
of ways of our technology and the response time
on things uh is is incredibly like impeccable
uh and it's so quick and it's only going to
get quicker yeah it's only it's only going to get
quicker and whether it be text form whether you're
talking about the there's more than like chat
EBT there's like other things out there that are
similar like a Chachi BT but then you know you
got the AI image generators that people really
love toying around with and then and we are on the
path like people can already do like those deep
fakes impersonationally those Tom Cruise ones that
you see all the time look amazing so I I like the
commentary on that um and I I think that the the
concept itself is really cool because there's ways
because there's many paths they could have gone
down with it of of of like living in this world of
what this AI is and the commentary on how what we
like I like the CEO line essentially talking about
that would they people were not responding to the
pleasantries of their life they're responding to
the neurotic sides of Our Lives because I'm
fascinated with real I am fascinated with
reality shows and why we love reality show so
much like it's really hard to find like a common
like a a real solid thing on like why
reality shows work so well for people
what the what the escapism is for it there's like
something there that people really do love because
it's an Escape from your own life you're just
watching someone else's life but how real is this
when there's cameras pointed at you and all these
things you know so the concept of this dramatized
thing is in some ways maybe even closer to reality
because you're not aware at all that there's
cameras like you're not aware there's surveillance
happening yeah and so your capture something real
but then it's also being enhanced with the writing
and the performances to add a little bit of extra
um to the dramatization of their lives so in a
way you're watching a blend of a reality show
meets a scripted adaptation of a real life
situation that someone's going through so I
think there's something really cool about it and I
feel like there's I feel like they could have done
a little bit more with like I don't know I mean
I like I like the route they went I did because
I think there's just so many different concepts
you could have done with this one concept yeah
that there's other variations would have liked
to have seen but maybe the other variations I
would have liked to have seen maybe not
would have worked for this episode of
you know like there's ways you could have used
it to to your control you know to like bolster
your own Fame become an influencer um the way how
reality show stars do that all the time you know
where they're on a reality show they're nobodies
and then like one of those and then they decide
like all right I'm gonna become an influencer
and I'm gonna you know get brand deals and and
use this as a way to promote myself you know or
like oh how can I control the narrative here yeah
and like what she does do uh so I did like that
but and I but I also love the idea of like the
celebrity getting upset about the way their
likeness is used because that is also a real
problem that has occurred as well yeah yeah you
know yeah yeah like giving it multiple like yeah
it's it feels like there are a bunch of levels you
could go through but at least using this scope of
yeah like some kind of piece of media yeah I mean
that's those are two huge things we're constantly
kind of hearing and talking about as regular
people being preyed upon by fine print and by
you know uh various kinds of latent surveillance
and then yeah likeness rights and the ghoulish
ways and like like it all kind of again it is kind
of surprising that Netflix I don't know it's never
really surprising because obviously they're just
gonna make money off of this and nothing's really
going to change in real life but it does kind of
point to like the only people really safe from
this if anybody is safe from this is like you know
the owner of the big Corporation who owns this
computer that nobody understands and I like that
they even addressed it like yeah nobody really
understands how this machine works or anything
it just kind of does its thing and we all watch
um but yeah like At first I thought it would
just be that one level of like oh what does the
normal person gonna do but no yeah Salma Hayek
is also in theory stuck in this situation too
and is also being exploited and everyone is
being handed a contract that is way too long
to understand and entrusting that to somebody
else who might not have their best interests at
heart and so yeah there were a lot of aspects
that felt very relevant wrapped up inside this
you know outlandish packaging uh yeah that again
you know I wonder if there were harsher versions
of this script and you know things that went
in even harder on you know what it's trying
to comment on that were maybe pulled back yeah
because I like the world that they presented at
the end of what they're they wanted their end
goal to be where everyone would have that yeah
because if everyone has that then Joe then Joan
have nothing to worry about yeah because then
she everyone would be aware that oh this is what
they do to all of us and then it could just become
fun watching how it works but then I was like
well everyone get a lot more relaxed about life
yeah and then I was also like but what would
that world entail I like I want to see that
world come to full realization of what would that
world and like this is one of those Black Mirror
episodes where like it would be cool to see like
a sequel to this but they shut down the servers
um of what would that world entail if everyone
has their own show so when the shows is it all
like crossovers like yeah but they're all watching
their own versions become where they're all just
watching versions of their friends and family yeah
totally uh and but if but like yeah it would be
cool to say like the version where people inhabit
it and embrace it uh instead of just only being uh
rebelling against it and and fighting against it
you know like there's it's a really it's a really
cool scenario um and so yeah I would have I would
have liked to have seen it because it did made me
Ponder like a bunch of questions and I do think in
our reality like the world we live in I feel like
yeah I I feel like that um I feel like a lot
of us would like that I think a lot of us would
embrace it because it would be exploitative of
our uh sure are very um our narcissistic sides
I think it would be real real telling of that and
I feel like a lot of us would hate it but I think
there'd be a lot of us who would really like it
too at the same time just to watch how it unfolds
and to watch it play out and stuff and there would
be people who would absolutely totally be down for
it so yeah so I wanted to see that version as well
like I'm not saying like this this show goes down
the episode goes down for me because we didn't
get that I was like I'm saying this is why I
like the concept so much yeah yeah because the the
possibilities of where this world building could
have gone with this one thing I was like oh it
didn't have to end here it it could have gone more
yeah they talk about multiverses and you really
do feel like yeah you could yeah you can see how
I don't know you want to see yeah how the like
the furthest extent of this goes instead of
breaking the machine while it's still kind of just
beginning to start this phenomenon like yeah what
would it like and maybe that's part of what's kind
of different now about the show is like this does
have like a a nice resolve and a happy ending I
guess I would call that which is not you know what
I usually typically associate black mirror with
and so yeah in some ways I feel like you could go
even further even more dystopic and yeah there
are like multiple extrapolations on this idea
and so I kind of do hope that maybe as like this
situation in real life expands they might come
back and touch back on it at some point like I
don't know Joan is the Revenge of Joan is awful
or something like that later down the line because
yeah like there are just so many implications and
we we mostly just watch as people are dismayed
by it but what about the people who love this
and what about the people who are only going to
become worse and and get higher and higher off
this experience of having this Spotlight thrust
upon them and whatnot like in reality shows I
think sometimes one of the fun parts of a reality
show is watching The Reunion because what happens
in a reunion is those people have had months
away from the events that happened and then
they come back and watch the reality show and see
how it's all edited and put together and see what
all their friends or family said when they weren't
around you know yeah and then in the reunion it's
a big confrontation of those things and I think
that would have been cool to see how watching
everyone else's shows would intersect is that
how you see me yeah how you appear in somebody
else's life show and it's like if we both have a
stream like if I have a stream Berry account and
John is a stream Berry account and we're in the
same room with the events of John show play out
different yeah in my show Even though perspective
yeah yeah that's what I mean I think I think there
was a lot of really cool things they could it's
you don't have time for all that that's like you
would have like a whole season you have to start
the episode out where it's already established
but yeah it's a very different episode not the
introduction of the first one it is it would have
to be like this is already happening yeah and
you're living they're plopping you into the a
world where this is already happening um so yeah
it would be cool to see like a follow-up for it
because I do think there's real complicated things
that could happen that would make for an even more
interesting conversation what they presented here
well yeah and with the idea just the final just
like it was seeing a version of this too where how
do people behave now that everyone accepts that
their life is on display versus finding out your
life has been put on display and like I think we
can all kind of relate to how you would react to
that whereas if this is just the norm I feel like
everyone would be a little bit different yeah you
know in their behavior and the way they approached
all of this yeah I don't know it's at least I I
at least appreciate that it is rich in ideas and
we can sit here and be like man there are just
so many ways you could take this in so many like
it's a rich idea and that's cool yeah I appreciate
that episode's quirky actor was still really good
um I enjoyed everyone's presence quite a lot
so yeah had a had a fun time with that one
had a fun time Black Mirror still gets it's
still thought provoking um and at the end
of the day that's what I really wanted was
just another thought-provoking Black Mirror
alrighty guys well what did you think about
this episode leave your thoughts down below uh
be sure to subscribe leave a like and let's end
this with a patreon John real quick off the top
of your ahead who would you want to see a stream
Berry show about make it fast come on John don't
think about it don't think about how to do that
thing John I want to interrupt me with the names
TV what's her show what's the Rio Hammond is
one of the best people on the patreon but I
know because my closed doors that there are
dark things lurking within yourself so she
appreciates it that night and I want to see
what that is all about and then what details
we're talking I want a guest star on your show
you know I mean she comes across so kind and so
selfless and so giving but at the end of the day
she comes home looks in the mirror is like yeah
look at you you're such a good person look at
how how much you do for the past she's a good
person yeah it sounds like a positive show
yeah yeah yeah I just heard talking herself
up the whole time and none of it's authentic
or real oh my God feed her ego and be loved by
everything really viewer my God I definitely
do this is all true it's not an algorithm
and uh terrible that's terrible what you're doing
her but I will be her biggest viewer and I will
tune into every episode and I'll be out there
Maria she's a real one don't trust the algorithm
I love you Maria don't listen to a word I said
it's all fake it's all fiction destroy the super
computer stay pledged we love you love you Maria
you know John didn't mean it I didn't mean it
you're uh awful Human music John is awful awful